first they're telling us that it's
because of putin's price hike but
apparently it's really if it wasn't
about that it's that biden is leading
and he has to show us he's leading how's
he leading well remember this
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
talked about food shortages and uh and
it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well that's leadership people food
shortages are coming and we're putting
the sanctions on that are causing them
leadership 101 if you look in the
dictionary under leadership it has joe
biden's confused face but you know that
the state of all of this is whacked out
when even on cnn the fictitious cartoon
network known as cnn when even they
even democrat activist jake tapper has
to acknowledge that some of this is bs
we were covering inflation long before
putin invaded ukraine inflation in the
united states in the last year
is
preceded this attack
and some people hear the president and
the white house blaming all of this on
putin and think
that's just not accurate that's just not
factual
hot diggity damn can we send jake tapper
a gift basket
what do we got we got some florida
orange we're gonna send him a copy of
the book tapper you got one right
i lost a bet who knew
it's not just cnn then there's this
mental institution msnbc with that
racist joy read they're even
acknowledging what's going on look at
this image very look at this up all the
stuff that you don't want up you'd want
down right now and generally speaking
you'd want down unless you were a
partisan maniac everything's up gas is
up about 50 used automobiles i mean this
is insane are up 35 because we're not
producing enough new ones hotels up 25 i
know all about that as i'm trying to go
on tour right now airfare i know all
about this one too about 24
furniture and bedding 16
meat poultry and eggs you guys all know
this when you're going shopping everyone
sees it major appliances are up cereal
baked goods about 10
this is all obvious and we know it but
it has nothing to do with them on one
hand because this is putin's price hike
but also joe biden's in charge and he
has to show people he's in charge none
of it makes sense so people
what is
the thing that ties today's show
together
you can either believe that these people
are in charge and are doing a good job
or you can believe that they are in
charge but actually it's putin who's
really in charge or you can believe that
they are intentionally wrecking any
everything or some version of all of
those things or
you can take a little responsibility for
your life
you can perhaps somehow in your life do
what elon musk is doing in his life and
i know it doesn't sound quite right it's
like wait a minute this guy's like a
trillionaire he's sending teslas into
space he's going to mars all of this
stuff it's like i'm i'm in no way
related to elon musk but he is one man
he is one human being and he started
doing something so whatever it is in
your life that you can do
whether it's you start growing some food
in your backyard which they don't want
you to do
whether it is that you cancel disney
plus that they don't want you to do
whether it is that you get your kids out
of public school so they don't believe
these clowns when they say this nonsense
that would be good there is a whole
bunch of stuff that you can do you can
stand your ground you can call out their
bs and you cannot vote for democrats you
do not have to be a republican but you
cannot be a democrat
that is the message and spread that to
your friends and start getting some
balls really more than anything i guess
that's really what it is start getting
some balls today is post woke day one